welcome to the reason live stream I am
Zach Weissmuller I am joined today it's
by uh two esteemed guests
um Dr Samuel Gregg uh a distinguished
fellow in political economy at the
American Institute for economic research
and contributing editor at law and
Liberty as well as author of the new
book the next American economy nation
state and markets in an uncertain world
as well as Russ green a senior fellow
for economic progress at stands together
a former CrossFit employee which is
actually how I first got to know him and
which I think we'll talk about a little
bit later and also husband to a great
former and hopefully future reason TV
contributor nor Greene
um thank you Bo uh thank you both for
joining me uh you've booked on some
really uh important work on today's
topic uh which is environmental social
and governance or ESG investing uh here
is uh Samuel's uh contribution to uh
recent law and Liberty uh Forum on the
topic why business should dispense with
ESG
uh this is Russ's contribution what are
the aims of business
um and uh I want to start with you uh
Sam uh you've elsewhere contemplated
whether uh this what what this whether
the rise of ESG also known as
stakeholder capitalism is a threat worse
than socialism so let's start by
defining terms as best we can what is
ESG in the broadest terms possible and
why is it a Potential Threat
well thanks for having me on uh Zach
it's great to be with you on reason TV
it's also good to be here with uh Russ
whose contributions to these this debate
I think has been um uh very important
ESG as the an acronym suggests
environmental social and governance is
the idea that businesses private
businesses whether they're single owner
or whether they are uh publicly traded
companies
um have a responsibility to include
among other goals not which at least
among which of course is the what I call
what I think is the T loss of business
which is of course profit and
shareholder value
that they have an obligation to be
pursuing other goals that are deemed to
be important for the overall what
well-being of society and that's
typically broken down in terms of
environmental issues social issues which
includes uh any number of particular
causes almost all of which I think would
be fairly described as Progressive
social causes and then governance issues
and the governance issues can range from
things like just good corporate
governance that we would normally expect
from publicly traded companies
to the idea that other entities other
what are called stakeholders have a role
in shaping the agenda and goals of a
given set of businesses or corporations
so that that's broadly speaking what it
it's about and in many respects it's not
a new thing because there have been lots
of attempts over the past 30 40 years to
try and move business in a direction
whereby profit and shareholder value
become one of just many particular goals
that people think businesses should be
pursuing a corporate social
responsibility was another of these
movements right back in the 1980s and
1990s so this is not a new phenomena
but it's taken on a much bigger profile
I think because uh so many uh very large
publicly traded corporations have
signaled very publicly
their adherence to this is a sort of
worthy thing that business should be
pursuing now we can get into the details
of whether businesses who who adopt this
rhetoric actually pursue that type of
um uh internal policy when it comes to
how they actually manage themselves
because one of the things I've
discovered there's often a big gap
between the rhetoric and the reality of
these things
but the the prominence that it's been
given by very major Business Leaders and
of course uh The Business Roundtable
statement of 2019 which was all about
stakeholder capitalism represented a
shift away from the brts traditional
focus upon shareholder value and this
movement of it at least in the direction
of saying well stakeholder capitalism is
here we have to pay attention to it Etc
it adds up I think to a broad attempt to
try and shift business away from what
it's supposed to do what it's really
defining purpose is and my fear is that
in the long term it's going to end up
with a lot of businesses understanding
themselves as being something between a
corporate a commercial Enterprise and a
type of mildly left-wing NGO so that's a
sort of broader broader problem I think
that's going on with this particular
movement and Russ uh do you broadly
agree with that characterization of what
ESG is would you add any modifications
and what do you view as kind of the big
the most concerning things about about
this development
yeah um I Sam primarily focused on the
firm level like at a single Corporation
um and and that that for the most part
is accurate
um but there's also always been a
systemic side to this right um ESG began
as a United Nations
hosted and convened Endeavor
um in 2004 and from the beginning you
can read their original documents uh one
of them is called who cares wins it was
always understood that ESG would
necessitate globally coordinating
Financial allocation and regulation
towards the un's sustainable development
goals so um you know why that is why
that it requires that sort of
coordination should be sort of
immediately obvious based on what Sam
said right because if you have just
individual companies deciding not to
invest in things for ideological reasons
you're really just creating
opportunities for other people you know
that you know in economics that's called
an Arbitrage opportunity right
um so you know that's a problem because
really you're not of you're not
advancing the political and social goals
that you're supposed to be advancing so
what they've always recognized from the
beginning
is that this required changing not just
single firm's Behavior but coordinating
among firms which of course raises
Anti-Trust concerns and also
coordinating government policy
right so the public pensions would have
to be managed differently
and um Financial Regulators would have
to prioritize ESG goals over the
traditional scope of practice so
um it and it's really astounding if you
look at these original United Nations
documents and and everything that's
contemplated way back in 2004 so much of
it has actually happened I mean I think
it's the first United Nations plan
that's actually worked right when I
studied them at Georgetown like we would
always laugh at the U.N like they've
never done anything what well well you
know they finally did something so good
for them but you know unfortunately for
us it's economically destructive
well I want to talk about uh you know
what some of those mechanisms for
coordination are because that that kind
of gets to the root of the of one of the
the issues here which is how much of ESG
you know is a market phenomenon and how
much of it is you know being imposed by
some sort of either government or you
know International body you know the way
one of the ways I started getting
interested in this was
um I read uh the book uh written by
Klaus Schwab the head of the world
economic Forum the great reset he's also
written a book about uh stakeholder
capitalism I I pulled a a clip uh from
him being interviewed uh about his book
and talking a little bit about it and I
think this clip might be able to get us
into a conversation about kind of how
this all works the Kobe kaises has shown
us that companies which were committed
to
stakeholder concept have performed much
better because they have invested into
the long-term Vitality of the company
so what we have to do now and what is
very important is to walk the talk and
walking to talk means not just to talk
about stakeholder capitalism but also to
establish a framework of metrics which
allow everybody to see so that the
company is performing
according to the ESG criteria
so there's two components there to what
he's saying first is that uh ESG through
the pandemic proves to be a good thing
because it incentivizes companies to
think longer term
um and so he's making an assertion that
companies that committed to ESG fared
better throughout the pandemic I would
be curious if you have any thoughts on
that or have seen as the empirical data
related to that uh the other part of his
claim is that
um you know or what he's calling for is
some sort of uh mechanism to better be
able to either rate or coordinate
whether companies are are actually
complying like setting some sort of I
guess Global ESG type standard
um so let's take the first part of that
first is there evidence that that ESG
was actually a good practice for
companies to make it through an
unexpected Global event like the
pandemic
well if I can if I'll go first before
Russ one thing I'll say is that in the
article that of mine that you put up at
the beginning of our conversation uh I
went through and actually looked at some
of the
um measurement not both the measurements
that were being applied by different ESG
ratings agencies and what you discover
is they're all over the place there's
very little consistency in terms of what
they're looking for how they measure how
they assess how they align different
numbers it's it's really very very messy
and anyone who knows anything about
statistics would recognize at the very
low rate of correlation across ESG
ratings agencies suggest that there's a
problem just with measuring these things
in the first place the second thing is
that there's also and I also talk about
this in the article there's also a fair
amount of evidence that suggests that
ESG funds don't actually perform better
then let's call them non-esg funds and
even worse the the main makeup of ESG
funds what distinguishes an ESG fund
from a non-esg fund can be something as
as little as the ESG fund puts two
percent of its investment in something
like I don't know wind energy or
something like that and that qualifies
it as an ESG fund so you start to see
that there are serious definitional and
measurement issues associated with ESG
which again I argue goes back to the I
think the blurriness of the concept
which is problematic but the other thing
which I think is important to keep in
mind with um Klaus Schwab and his
particular Vision on stakeholder
capitalism
my argument is that he's basically
advocating for what we would call
corporatism this is the control
mechanism that he has in mind
corporatism in the sense that
um there's a coordination between
business and government and ngos and
unions that seeks to sort of sort of
pursue particular goals at the ex more
or less at the expense of profit so
markets are not pushed out of the
picture altogether private property
isn't abrogated altogether but
everything is much more subject to a
top-down focus upon stability and the
realization of goals that are marginal
to the purpose of business and it's also
the other thing to keep in mind I think
is that some of this is already starting
to be regulated through things like this
the SEC the SEC under its particular
under its present leadership
has pretty much made it clear that
they're going to try and push companies
down this particular path and that I
think is is very worrisome because it
goes back to something that Russ said
that this stuff is starting to get legal
and Regulatory traction now and once
that happens it's really difficult to
reverse it and how how much uh of it at
this point in time Russ is do you think
due to uh you know regulatory efforts or
is this pretty much you know a market
phenomenon at this point you know
there's this one uh chart I wanted to
bring up that you reference in one of
your articles and it's showing uh
investment that adheres to this un
standard called principles for
responsible investment um and you can
see it's it's gone up up over time
um that might be you know one sort of
proxy for like how influential is ESG
but maybe you could just explain you
know what you think that that this this
chart means and why it is that so many
businesses are or so many firms are
converging on this
yeah so going back to what Sam said
about corporatism one of the defining
features of corporatism is it becomes
increasingly difficult to actually
delineate between the public sector and
the private sector right and that means
that answering your question is very
hard so so one example of that would be
if you listen to Larry Fink who's the
CEO at BlackRock speak he'll say like
look at the end of the day I'm really
just responding to what my customers
want you know so if you just hear that
right off the bat you think oh okay he's
just responding to you know basically
what uh private sector customers want
but that's actually not the case right
because if you look at who BlackRock and
you know and not just them any large
asset manager who many of their largest
customers are we're talking about public
pension plans
right the Calpers calstrs right the New
York state right and and these are you
know they're run by governments right
and then in addition to that you know
obviously
um a BlackRock has very significant
dealings with um the Chinese government
as well so um there are very significant
levers of power that are being exerted
to push ESG and then um even Beyond
explicit policy there's also implicit
threats right that if you think of the
period
um during which
ESG uh was really uh Rising fast two
things were happening
um one um you know and this goes to your
earlier question uh you know markets are
cyclical right so there was a period of
time where um tech companies which tend
to do better on ESG we're doing really
well in sectors like mining or energy
what sometimes referred to as the old
economy was underperforming so it
actually made sense for that very
specific period of time
um to favor ESG allocation at the same
time too if you recall um there were
proposals like Elizabeth Warren's
accountable capitalism act
um and it it the progressive wing of the
democratic party was really on the rise
like if you think back to the primaries
of 2020
um like the proposals that were being
discussed prior to Biden becoming the
nominee were really out there so
corporations were looking at that like
oh that's the future and we have to
prepare for that right so there's um
there was a policy risk and reputational
risk angle to this which is that es by
committing to ESG they're not just
responding to existing demands from
governments but also anticipating future
policies
this uh this uh uh um accountable
capitalism act that you mentioned uh one
of the components of it is that U.S
corporations would be required to allow
their workers to elect 40 percent of the
members of their board of directors
um and it's not just kind of the
Elizabeth Warren wing of the democratic
party that's talking about this you know
our president uh ran uh kind of echoing
that message you know kind of
incorporating that in into his rhetoric
I have I've got a a clip from Biden
talking a little about this that I'll
play real quick it's way past time to
put an end to the era of shareholder
capitalism
the idea the only responsibility a
corporation has is shareholders
that's simply not true it's an absolute
Force
to have responsibility to their workers
their Community to their country
that is a newer radical notion
so I mean he says it's it's not a new or
a radical notion and this kind of goes
back to a debate that uh you know has
been raging for a long time at the this
article I just brought up is uh the
so-called freedmen Doctrine Milton
Friedman's
um famous you know New York Times essay
saying that the social responsibility of
business is to increase its profits and
to you know increase shareholder value
uh and that anything beyond that is kind
of a distraction and this is kind of
like an unwinding of that over over the
uh over the following decades but you
know what what would be
what are the possible
downsides of something like increasing
worker uh you know worker power uh the
power of Labor to determine the
composition of a corporate board it kind
of sounds I'm sure to a lot of Americans
that sounds like a good thing it's like
sticking it to
um the the powerful uh billionaire CEOs
who um you know are are are hoarding all
the money but what are the possible
downsides of that um well there are
quite a few and we know this because uh
the model that's being proposed
literally having
workers elected to boards what they
really mean of course are Trade union
officials that's who the people are that
would be elected under this scheme and
we know this because this is precisely
what happens in for example contemporary
Germany and even to a certain extent
auster and some other European countries
where some of this is already mandated
by law and it's a classic it's called
workered co-determination
and this is a classic corporatist move
if you look at most corporatist uh
regimes this is one of the things they
stress over and over again and of course
worker really means Trade union official
we need to be clear about that and one
of the things that it results in is that
that remember that the Trade union
official is not so interested in things
like how entrepreneurial the company is
going to be whether it's going to seize
seize advantages whether it's going to
be nimble and to adjust to new
circumstances the Trade union official
was interested in stability of
employment stability of currently
employed employees what this means is
that anything that comes along whether
it's new technology or a change in
market conditions or um a new
entrepreneurial invention that
challenges a particular way of doing
things in a given industry the Trade
union official is not going to be saying
well we need to take advantage of that
and maybe that needs we need to fire
some people and bring some people on if
we go to maintain our existence let
alone profit as a company they'll say no
we we want the status quo to mean to
stay in place and that's one reason I
think you find average levels of
productivity in so many of these
particular countries considerably lower
than those countries that do not have
these types of arrangements and at its
worst it facilitates outright corruption
the Volkswagen Corporation in the 2000s
is a classic example of that it needed
to make some adjustments to change
market conditions they found that the
union officials on the board and the
work what's called the work Council were
not amenable to these changes until what
Volkswagen Corporation decided to start
literally bribing
to change their position on these sorts
of things
so and I talk about this quite a lot in
my book the next American economy on the
chapter on stakeholder capitalism
because it shows again
that what's behind this are not new
ideas this is very much a type of
corporatist mentality under a different
lexicon that's being brought to bear
upon the way we talk about these
questions today
right so that's that's something
actually that Biden's right about that
it's not it's not some new and crazy
idea it goes back over a hundred years
we've been having this sort of debate uh
you know one thing I would add though is
I think when the stakeholder capitalism
advocates
um speak they make sort of a false
equivalence which is that sort of they
say well you know now we have
shareholder Primacy and we need to move
to a system of stakeholder capitalism so
that companies can put stakeholders
first you know as if right now we have a
top-down mandate that everyone's got to
do shareholder Primacy and you know
really we just have to move towards a
Freer system so they have the option to
do stakeholder capitalism that's
completely false just completely false
um right now if if you want to start a
company that is a hundred percent
committed to stakeholder capitalism you
can incorporate as a benefit corporation
which Most states have that option and
it will be in your Charter um for the
lifetime of your corporation that you
can put your stakeholders first right
you can do that right now you can do
that
um when you see that most companies
especially the highest uh most valued
companies are not doing that that's due
to a choice that they made right because
you have a choice not just how you
incorporate in this country but also
where you incorate and it turns out that
most not all but most publicly traded
companies are Incorporated in Delaware
which tends to be more of a shareholder
Primacy friendly state so it's not at
all the case right now that you're
forced into shareholder Primacy it's
simply the case that that's where you
know markets over time have you know
favor things to go but it again if you'd
rather do business a different way you
have that option I'm curious Russ like
what what you think about you know to
that point going back to the the
Friedman doctrine that the social
responsibility of business is to
increase its profit so he's making a
declaration Beyond
um you know what government should do
he's saying actually this is just what
any businessman should be focused on and
he goes so far to say that businessmen
who talk about things like uh you know
social responsibility
um or you know social conscious are
unwitting puppets of the intellectual
forces that have been undermining the
basis of a free Society these past
decades
um do you buy that or is there actually
room in a free market for you know
different forms of of business or
different objectives to be uh sought by
by a firm
yeah I mean I understand where he's
coming from you have to put this in
context right I believe that was
published in 1970 or 1971. um you know
that that's a period of inflation
economic stagnation
um and also you know I I would agree
with the point that many Business
Leaders who talk about ESG and
stakeholders do so in a way that is
absolutely undermining the pillars of a
free and open Society because you know
very often it's intertwined with this
idea of public-private partnership and
even corporations uh basically becoming
cartels so um that's bad
um but I do not accept the point
um that any Corporation pursuing any
objective you know that's different than
shareholder value maximization is just
per se wrong
um you know you mentioned my experience
at CrossFit
um you know so actually before I talk
about CrossFit 2 I should highlight a
key difference between privately held
and publicly held corporations right and
in actually
um I in some ways I feel like Friedman
was being overly broad
um right now there's about 6 000
um publicly held corporations in the
country but there are millions of
privately held ones
and if you're a privately held
Corporation you know with just one owner
or several owners it's fairly simple if
you want to prioritize something other
than shareholder value you certainly
have that option
um and you don't have to ask you know
your thousands of shareholders for
permission because they don't exist
right so that you know that was my
experience at CrossFit CrossFit most of
the time I was there was owned entirely
by one person you know Greg Glassman and
you know he explicitly said like you
know our priority in business is not
making money you know we think that
making money is a reflection of the
value that we're creating for other
people you know so he defined business
as the Art and Science of creating
uniquely attractive opportunities for
other people and this is a bit of a
sidebar but it's really interesting
because we would go up every fall to
Harvard Harvard University over the
course of about five years and Greg
would present there and he would speak
to two schools
the business school and the Divinity
School so I'm going to get to I'm going
to put the Divinity School to the side
for a second the business school when he
first went there and started speaking
this was maybe like 2013 14-ish
um and he would say like look business
isn't about making money it's about you
know creating value for other people
the students were like shocked and
appalled and they were just incredulous
right but towards the tail end you know
by 2018 2019 when he would go and speak
they would you know still be arrogant of
course the Harvard students but it was
the opposite right they were like of
course you're saying that we all know
this right like business isn't about
making money so we saw that switch
happen in real time at you know
America's Elite business school and also
in some sense I think it's a good thing
you know I I obviously am very proud of
my time at CrossFit
um there are thousands of independently
owned businesses you know that still
exist um to this day
um due to CrossFit and I think it's
improved the lives of millions of people
um and I don't think it would have been
effective if it had been a public health
Corporation really prioritizing you know
how do we maximize our stock price or
our quarterly earnings
it certainly would have would not have
had the same Community spirit that it
had it always felt like it was more than
just a company right and it's hard to do
that if it's you know immediately
apparent that you know management is
trying to squeeze you out of every dime
and another example of uh you know
someone who has taken a slightly
different philosophical approach to
running his business is John Mackey the
outgoing CEO of Whole Foods and
nicolespie interviewed him earlier this
year I'm going to play a brief fight
from that interview in a second where
they talked about ESG because Mackie was
one of the most uh kind of outspoken
proponents of this idea of conscious
capitalism right which is the idea that
you can harness the power of capitalism
and and profit for some positive social
good which obviously is an intention
with that Friedman Doctrine we were just
talking about but at the same time he
has a deep uh suspicion and critique of
ESG so I just like just to play this bit
from Mackie and get your reaction to
what he's saying worries me right now is
that I mean conscious capitalism is a
management philosophy it's a way you
should manage your business you should
figure out what the higher purpose of
your business is
um and that's always going to be in
value creation for other people yeah
it's about whatever it is you're
creating some value for other people or
you wouldn't have a business in the
first place Whole Foods is higher
purpose is to nourish people in the
planet secondly it's about the
stakeholders that they all matter and
they're interdependent and then it's
about creating you know leadership
that's more awake more conscious and
then cultures that poor people flourish
that's the four pillars of conscious
capitalism but I'm very concerned that
people are that it's being co-opted that
uh it's it's a management philosophy
it's not a governance system so ESG
and I'm oftentimes being having to
defend conscious capitalism which is
being conflated with ESG thinking which
is basically a political philosophy
that's trying to force corporations to
adhere to their particular political
philosophies and taking away power from
the shareholders that's really what it's
about that's not what conscious
capitalism the conscious capitalism is a
philosophy a way to think about your
business that is just a little bit more
enlightened a little more and I think
it's going to be a more successful way
to manage your business as well it's not
about distorting the governance system
to to take away the power from the
investors that will screw up capitalism
and maybe I think that's the intention
all alarm
so what do you uh make of that uh Sam
because I uh you know he he's saying
there that this that there's a
difference between a management
philosophy where you're kind of weighing
these different concerns versus a
governance structure uh is that
legitimate or does one kind of
necessarily lead to or flow into the
other yeah you know he's making some I
think important distinctions and nuanced
uh differences which I think if you look
at it closely it it it sort of adds up
what he's trying to do I mean one thing
I do think is important in this
discussion is that in a free market
economy if a business wants to set
itself up along the conscious capitalism
lines of John Mackey then you know if
it's privately owned and it's if
everyone knows what they're getting into
when they invest in their company
that's fine but what he's because I
think that's that's part of the freedom
that markets give you is you can
experiment with different types of
business models and different um types
of even business philosophies if you
want but what he's pointing to I think
is this problem of ESG being effectively
mandated
because that I think is really what the
long-term objective is is to mandate
this stuff
and even if you go back and you look at
say Friedman's article Friedman does not
say that business is free to just simply
ignore this social environment around
them he doesn't say that business has a
license to engage in willful destruction
of the environment he doesn't say that
businesses shouldn't be conscious of the
type of communities they're working in
he's very clear that any sound any sane
business leader is going to pay
attention to those sorts of things but
that's different from making those sorts
of things part of the actual objective
and then mandating it for the rest of
society
um because I and I think this is another
point which uh it's worth keeping in
mind here and I say this in a lot of
different contexts uh being pro-business
and being pro market are not the same
thing
they're generally not the same thing and
what Friedman is pointing to in his
article
is Business Leaders many of them are
looking for opportunities for collusion
for cronyism for ways of protecting
themselves against Market pressures and
I would argue that in some respects ESG
is operating in some of the in a certain
way like that now so for example
um in my article on this subject I I
quoted from a McKinsey article McKenzie
is
woke Management on stilt as far as I'm
concerned they really are but if you
look at what they say so they
acknowledge that there are lots of
critiques now coming out about ESG and
they even say some of these critiques
are accurate but then they go on and say
well basically if you don't accept ESG
then you endanger your quote social
license to operate
so I don't know how to interpret that as
anything else but I sort of implied
threat that if you don't Embrace these
ideas then somehow you're going to be
pushed out by regulation or other
different forms of coercion from being
able to operate in the marketplace
alongside other other companies so this
is this is the sort of Insidious side I
think it because I think that there
there are many respects they're
misrepresenting what Friedman said but
also they're getting to the point now
whereby they're using ESG a lot of
businesses are starting to use this as a
way to invoke regulation against actual
competitors and potential competitors as
well well just to try to make and I
almost hesitate to do this but to try to
make the uh the case for that or that is
being put forth for stakeholder
capitalism uh just to have you respond
to you know what what they're trying to
achieve here which is that we in the
21st century we're all you know
interconnected to a degree we never have
been before we've got Global problems
they're recognizing that markets are
good and uh that markets can can achieve
goals and so the the best thing we can
do like they're moving beyond something
like uh uh communism and saying that the
best way to to address these these
externalities that that result from a
free market like environmental
degradation
um or kind of uh uh you know the effect
on local communities and and health and
so forth is to just integrate that into
the market system so this is in a way
you know Elizabeth Warren who we talked
about earlier frames it as she's trying
to kind of fortify or save capitalism
um so that it can continue
um in this this global economy
what do you uh what is wrong with with
that reasoning
or what would be a better way to address
the the externalities that I think we
all would agree occasionally you know
sometimes do
um do arise from from Market
transactions is that for me Zach or is
that for Sam oh yeah let's go why don't
you take that Russ and then yeah Sam can
jump in if he has anything to add
yeah so I there I mean
first of all it's it's that argument you
know usually insinuates that ESG is just
a private sector action and as we've
discussed up to this point you know that
couldn't be further from the truth
there's always been a policy side to it
and especially in recent years that
policy side is you know gone from zero
to a hundred frankly you know and it's
not you know to Sam's earlier point it's
not just the SEC there's a whole of
government push to
um basically incorporate ESG
um into everything the government is
doing
um so you know if you want to look into
that there's executive order 14030 on
climate risk um there's another
executive order on racial equity and you
know essentially what they're saying is
is again not just the Securities and
Exchange Commission but every organ of
government needs to be prioritizing you
know these objectives and you know that
inevitably comes at the expense of other
things
um but even if we were to X accept the
point that you know well you know there
are externalities which you know of
course they're externalities but even if
we were to accept that point
um the question then becomes is ESG the
right way to respond to them
um I would say no absolutely not
um for a couple reasons one you know as
we've discussed ESG pressure is
primarily exerted on Western publicly
traded companies right
um in order to even um be effective on
esg's own terms it would need to be
applied globally but it's not
so what happens when you're exclusively
applying ESG pressure on American and
European companies and not say on
Chinese companies is you're creating
economic opportunities for other
countries
right because for if we zero in on
energy for example since a lot of the
interest in this is around climate
change and carbon emissions
um when Exxon Mobil for example
um decides that it's cutting its
investment in future production and as a
result of that it's pulling out of a
field in the south of Iraq
that Field's not going to lie fallow
right another country is going to invest
in it and most of these most of these
other investors are sovereign firms so
it's not even a privately held you know
uh to the extent that's even a thing a
Chinese company
um it's a Chinese state-owned company or
it's you know an Iraqi company you know
so basically it's OPEC plus which is all
the OPEC nations plus Russia or it's
China coming in so you're not actually
creating any environmental benefit
you're really just transferring value
from the West
to the rest and you know often very
often these new um uh the new investors
actually have lower environmental and
social standards so it's a national
security problem but it's not even it's
not even good for there's no benefit
right it's just Cost
um and
even you know even further than that
um
it's it's hard to imagine how any of
this could be fixed because
um is anyone going to trust China to
comply with ESG commitments again it's
against its own National interest they
would never do that only a Western
Country would be stupid enough to do
that
you know just to add on that point about
I'm very glad that Russ mentioned China
because it points to what I would call
the the selectivity problem that a lot
of ESG has so for example I remember
debating back in January a Stanford
Professor who's a proponent of DSG and
she was making some interesting points
and I just responded I said well you
know I find it interesting that I hear a
lot from ESG Advocates about different
human rights abuses around the world and
this is a problem and private companies
and shareholdering companies shouldn't
be in any position whereby they're
they're helping this happen etc etc let
alone profiting from it but I said I
haven't I don't notice ESG funds talking
very much about China
and the growth of uses of human rights
that are going on in China I didn't
notice ESG funds and outfits talking
very much about Russia until Russia
invaded Ukraine now the Putin regime was
in place a long time before the Ukraine
Invasion uh the the Chinese Communist
Regime has been in place a long time
before it started behaving the way it's
been behaving for a while and the
response that I got was well businesses
have to deal with reality they have to
deal with these different circumstances
they can't be too picky about these
things in other words the the the double
standard that inevitably starts to
emerge when you take it particularly as
as Russ has pointed out on a number of
occasions from The Firm level to the
political and Global level you start to
see the inconsistencies in the
incoherence of the system because if
you're going to be against companies uh
doing things that might contribute to or
at least prop up regimes around the
world that you don't like then you've
got to apply that across the board right
so that means China that means Russia
that means all sorts of very unpleasant
regimes that a lot of the ASG people
just didn't want to talk about
until it became impossible not to the
last thing I'll say is in terms of the
sort of double standards we we talked a
little bit about the Business Roundtable
at the beginning right their 2019
statement well there's been some very
good research done by some people at
Harvard Business School that both Russ
and I have talked about on different
occasions uh pointing out that if you
look at the firms that signed up to the
brt's renewed statement of purposes for
them for corporations and you look at
the at their their internal bylaws and
how they operate
very few of them have actually changed
to adopt more of a stakeholder model so
that's just an empirical example of the
difference between the rhetoric that we
hear from a lot of companies about this
and the way that they behave now that's
not to take away from what Russ and I
are both pointing to which is the very
dangerous political dimension of this
the way in which this is being used by
more or less progressives to try and
reshape re-engineer the way that
economies work but the degree of
hypocrisy about this I think is worth
mentioning because it shows the
difference between
um the way that people talk about this
and what they actually do in practice
there's uh I pulled a couple examples of
what you're talking about I think with
the uh kind of selectivity or the double
standards this is Elon Musk tweeting he
he calls ESG a scam he's mad because uh
Tesla didn't make the list for the best
top the top 10 best in the world for
environment social and governance by S P
500 while Exxon did uh there's this
um there's this report that came from uh
some Utah lawmakers who were divesting
kind of state funds from ESG that part
of their reasoning was that Russian
energy Giants gas prom and rust Neff
outscored American energy companies
Exxon Mobil and Chevron on the S P's ESG
scale and that's despite the fact that
Putin is the majority owner of gas prom
there's also some mention of Chinese
companies down there which we all know
the government also has a majority stake
in so what is the actual reason for that
why are these authoritarian countries
getting kind of higher rankings uh on
higher ESG rankings what explains it
what's the mechanism
well one I'll just say 1.0 and then I'll
let Russ say something it's partly
because of something I mentioned before
which I talk about in my
um my initial article on this in law and
Liberty about this which is the
incoherence of the measurement system
and the if you look across the board
there's I think there's only something
like 52 correlation between the
different ratings that are used by these
particular types of agencies and anyone
who knows anything about ratings will
tell you that that's that shows a fair
amount of disagreement and
um dissonance about what counts as ESG
and what doesn't which is just part of
the problem because when when you can't
actually Define what it means and it
means whatever you want it to mean and
that's particularly problematic for for
obvious reasons I think
yeah and and I would also emphasize you
know again this started at the United
Nations right and you know that's
significant because uh historically
there's been a frankly a double standard
um which is that if a Western Country
like such as the United States
um which has been decreasing its you
know carbon dioxide emissions uh fairly
consistently for over a decade
um where the United States is constantly
attacked
um for um climate reasons whereas China
which emits more than the United States
the European Union and India all
combined and is increasing every year
and is investing enormous amounts in
coal and natural gas
China is praised at for its climate
action which cannot be justified on a
scientific basis
um and it really comes down to this
conceit that essentially China is part
of the global south or it's a developing
nation and therefore it cannot be held
to the same standard as the European
Union in the United States so this
double standard really has been baked
into the system from the beginning and
and there's another aspect of this which
it you know should be seen as uh
modifying or adding Nuance to what I
said about CrossFit earlier which is
that a lot of this is sort of a
replacement religion
right you know that when you point out
these when you point out these just very
practical and logical objections to ESG
people very rarely change their minds
which suggests that it's about something
else right there's a Invincible
ignorance aspect to this so
um you know when we would go to Harvard
you know uh us you know all the CrossFit
people
uh we would not just speak to the
business school people but also to the
Divinity School
and Harvard Divinity School had a group
of atheists there who had put out a
report called
um How We Gather and it said that
there's this whole generation of young
people who have no religion but they are
turning to corporations mostly as a
replacement for religion and one of the
corporations they highlighted was
CrossFit and I was actually I thought
this was very cool at the time right
that we were such a powerful community
and we're you know and that's all true
and we're improving people's lives but
you know the the truth of the matter is
is that corporations cannot replace your
family corporations cannot replace your
church corporations can do a whole lot
of good in the world but they have a
separate function
um you know again I stand by the claim
that that function doesn't necessarily
have to be shareholder value
maximization but they do have a separate
function from a church or a family or a
community organization right and I think
confusing those things is actually very
dangerous
um socially and you know you can look at
examples of that of companies that
really went all in on that sort of
corporate religion angle uh you know
it's it's stuff like if you've seen Adam
Newman at wework if you've seen the
documentaries about him he was all about
that right he was saying like this new
enlightened generation doesn't need
property and don't you want to live in a
community and meanwhile his whole bet is
on him owning real estate right or um
you know you've got Sam Bateman free
it's the exact same thing right
effective altruism in many ways is sort
of a a new modern religion and that's of
course all covering up for the fact that
he's committing fraud on a on a
historically massive scale and you know
we could list off five other examples
right and you know the problem is is
that we have we have spiritually hunger
hungry people and we also have people
who are just lonely they're looking for
communities and corporations and other
people politicians for sure are
exploiting them by selling them on you
know the these hopes and dreams so it's
um I think it's not just politically
problematic and economically problematic
but I also worry about the long-term
social
can I add one thing to that because I
think this is really important
um what's interesting about this phenomo
and I again this is one of the things I
focus on about that business has a
distinct purpose that's why it's not a
family that's why it's not the military
that's why it's not a religious
organization
it's I I tend to think about these
things in Aristotelian terms that the
tea loss of business is a very specific
thing notwithstanding Russ's point about
it can be more relatively expansive
depending on who owns the business but
the moment a business starts behaving
like a family or a family like a
business there's bound to be all sorts
of uh social uh dysfunctionalities that
go along with that and the second thing
I'd add though is that I think it also
reflects a lack of confidence among a
lot of business Executives and business
owners about the good that they do
precisely by being in business and
pursuing comments because yes it
produces a profit but think about all
the different things that that profit
enables that the company doesn't
consciously choose but which happen as
unintended side effects whether it's
more jobs or higher wages in some
instances or giving people capital and
financial resources to do all sorts of
things that have nothing to do with the
economy and business people in my
experience are generally not very good
at explaining this dimension of business
and and presenting business this way as
a worthwhile worthy vacation that's just
as good as being a doctor or being a
professor or whatever it happens to be
and I think a lot of business people
they latch on to these things whether
it's ESG or in the past Corporate social
responsibility oh no don't worry we are
good people we really are good people
we're not just concerned with this dirty
profit staff we're concerned with the
glow we're concerned with the
environment and that I think is it it
speaks to a problem that the business
Community has in defending and
explaining to people what it does
well if we accept that framing that
there's a sort of Quasi religious aspect
to it um you know the the punishment for
speaking out against a religion is
usually some sort of excommunication and
it's something that seems to have
happened occasionally uh in the
corporate world I know this is something
that you've pointed out in your article
Sam uh s uh hsbc's head of responsible
investing was suspended and then
eventually quit after a speech that he
gave questioning some of the tenets of
uh ESG I'm gonna play just a short clip
from his speech so people can get a
sense of of what he was saying I feel
like it's getting a little bit out of
hand the constant reminder that we are
doomed the constant reminder that within
decades it's all over we've got
Regulators in the US trying to stop us
we've got the China problem we've got a
housing crisis looming we've got
interest rates going up we're we've got
inflation coming down the pipes and I'm
being told to spend time and time again
looking at something that's going to
happen in 20 or 30 years hence the
proportionality is completely out of
whack
and I should have set that up a little
bit better he's talking about kind of
the all the compliance to uh you know
make sure HSBC is meeting uh climate
emissions goals and you you know that so
so much of his time is just being uh
eaten up with this thing when uh kind of
all the market indicators show that he
should be focused on much more pressing
problems and then after this he's
basically pressured out so are are are
we in danger of kind of a chilled debate
around this within you know we can all
sit here and talk about it on the stream
but really it's important for people in
the corporate world to be able to talk
about it and debate these ideas
um is that open debate happening well I
I'll go quickly first and I'll say that
um it's interesting that most of the
people who have talked about this
um in the way that you're describing are
usually former Executives of whatever
the company happens to be so there's
been a number for example of former
BlackRock Executives who have after
leaving the company
publicly stated
um this is somewhat of a farce it
doesn't work it's misleading it's
distracting us from some significant
major problems
and there are also there are some likes
Terence keenly in his recent book I
think it's called um sustainable who was
the former head of this for BlackRock
and he's come out and said now he's not
against the goal so let's be clear about
that he's not against the gods but he
says as a method and a strategy that
it's actually in the long term he thinks
very damaging for corporations and what
I found interesting about his
intervention is that uh first of all I
think it was Larry Fink who wrote
forward for the book which to my mind
tells you that there are significant
people in in Corporate America who are
now starting to realize you know maybe
we may have wandered too far down this
path and maybe we need to retract
ourselves a bit especially given
something that um Russ and I have talked
about a little bit which is the the Deep
unpopularity now of corporate America
not just on the left where it's always
been deeply unpopular but now on the
right as well and the unpopularity of
corporate America on the right so to
speak
um really started around about
2019. so this is not about Trump this is
not about all these other things this is
I think in some respect linked to the
fact that business is now seen by many
people partly because of the types of
goals that are associated with ESG as
hostile actively hostile to things that
at least one half of the country thinks
is important so business is it is not
careful it's going to find itself
beleaguered not just on the left which
they're more or less used to but
increasingly on the right and we're even
seeing Republican Senators now basically
saying to corporations that come forward
and say can you give us a break on this
can you help us out with this they're
basically saying buddy you're on your
own as long as you keep up with this ESG
woke staff
we have nothing to talk about yeah and
just to follow up on that real quick you
know we've talked a lot about the
environmental aspect of this but there's
also the the social uh uh plank
um and I know you've written a lot about
the diversity uh kind of initiatives
that are embedded in ESG Sam and uh the
fact that their ratings can be tied to
you know the makeup of uh someone's uh
Workforce or a corporate board and again
to many people
maybe that sounds like a good thing it
sounds like conscious capitalism but
what are some of the main problems with
implementation
well you know first of all when they
talk about diversity it's it's all about
racing sex it's all about racing sex
it's not about religious affiliation
it's not about your political
inclinations it's all about race and sex
so it's diverse in some respects but
it's clearly not diverse in other
respects and if you look at some of the
some of the the um the funds or the the
owning corporations of these funds that
and you dig down and you discover this
is what they actually mean by diversity
they don't mean Viewpoint diversity that
is very clear they're not into Viewpoint
diversity
um so that's one thing so that's a
problem so in other words it's
misrepresenting I mean I I don't even
like the word diversity I think
pluralism is a much better word I think
of what America is about when it comes
to understanding these things
but the other
um the other problem I think is that
um it could easily end up you could
easily end up with people being
appointed to positions simply because
they are of a particular skin color or
whatever it happens to be
but they don't actually know anything
about the area they're not particularly
skilled or experienced they may even
have a lousy track record in business
but if they're being appointed people
are being appointed on the basis of skin
color or whatever it happens to be
that suggests to me that there's a
serious risk that you will end up
appointing people who don't know what
they're doing and that's risky for the
company that's risky for shareholders
that's risky for the long-term
sustainability of the entire Enterprise
what have been the real world problems
and results on the energy side of things
Russ because you know the the ESG
investing is just pushed uh kind of a
lot of money towards certain companies
and away from uh or I should even say
certain sectors in a way uh from other
sectors
um and we've seen kind of what has
happened in Europe as of late uh with
with their dependence on for instance
Russian uh gas and oil
um has ESG uh you know since so much uh
money uh as we showed earlier has been
uh kind of put under its umbrella
um are there any you know measurable
real world effects when it comes to
something as fundamental as energy
yes so I did want to add on the
diversity point before I answer to that
question
um so
um I highly recommend the work of David
Bernstein who's a professor at George
Mason University School of Law of the
work he's done on racial categories
um you know look
a couple weeks ago so check that out uh
as well if you're watching racism is
absolutely a problem but race itself is
the social construct so when these
companies are bragging about their
diversity data they're by and large
relying on the US government's diversity
uh or racial categories which absolutely
are indefensible scientifically they
make no sense so if you if you are a
European person from Spain Your Mark has
Hispanic hence diverse but if you are a
refugee from Afghanistan or from uh
Morocco or you know the entire Middle
East you are not and there is no ex
there's no rational explanation for that
and I don't think anyone could believe
that someone from Spain is likely to
face more racial discrimination than
someone from Afghanistan or Iran or
Egypt that that's just facially absurd
so you know they these companies that
are bragging about their diversity
statistics are buying into a broken
system that has absolutely no
intellectual defense that's Point number
one on on energy
um yes uh this goes back to what I said
earlier which is that when um American
predominantly public companies
um divest from oil and gas production
um that's mainly just creating economic
opportunities for other nations for us
very often hostile foreign Nations
um and uh
that's um so very often the defense of
ESG is look we don't divest right like
uh BlackRock and others were very will
very often say like look we're some of
the largest shareholders in Exxon in
Chevron example uh for you know for
example
um and the problem with that is what
they're doing is actually worse
because if they were just not investing
in Exxon then other people would
and there would really be no disruption
but what's happening is that ESG
investors have have moved from
divestment or that's called ESG
screening to
um what's now called ESG engagement and
what engagement means is they um and you
have to keep in mind right that what's
who are known as The Big Three asset
managers so BlackRock State Street and
Vanguard
um generally are going to vote 25 of the
shares at any given publicly traded
Corporation and then you add the proxy
advisory firms who are also all in on
ESG so that's ISS and glass Lewis you
know we're talking about you know like
50 of the um votes at any publicly
traded company so they're very
influential and they have
um a lot of pressure that they can bring
to bear on these companies if they do
not comply right so um what's happening
instead of just BlackRock not investing
in in oil and gas companies ESG
investors invest with them
but then um push them towards themselves
investing Less in future production
so the locus of divestment has shifted
from portfolio level to now firm level
and as we discussed earlier when Exxon
invests less
it's um it the total amount of oil in
gas production doesn't go down but
instead it's shifted to countries that
are hostile to the United States and
therefore absolutely going to use it as
leverage against the United States
whether that's Russia as you mentioned
or whether that's OPEC or whether that's
China
oh and then I I didn't answer one of
your questions earlier which is that if
ESG doesn't work what does right like
what's the answer to this because there
absolutely are externalities right and I
think there's actually uh one of the
things I'm optimistic about is I think
there's an increasing awareness in both
the left and right that government
is one of the biggest barriers to
producing more clean energy
and that innovation
not hiring hundreds of thousands of ESG
Consultants but actual Innovation is
going to answer a lot of these problems
but it's very difficult for this
Innovation to occur because of all the
government barriers whether you're
talking about small modular nuclear
reactors or whether you're talking about
the sheer amount of Permitting that it
takes to you know for example
um you know create new solar energy or
do wind energy and and and let's not
forget too that ESG very often is biased
against this so ESG will punish utility
companies for investing in nuclear
energy
ESG investors
um look at scans for example at mining
but the truth is if you want a whole lot
more renewable energy and more electric
vehicles you're going to need tons more
copper and lithium and rare earth
minerals you're going to need a whole
lot more mining but environmentalists
and ESG investors very often do not want
that to occur in the United States so
it's not just the uh problem with oil
and gas that we talked about earlier
where that's being transferred overseas
but also we're increasing our dependence
on on on foreign hostile Supply chains
unnecessarily due to over regulation and
ESG pressure because now when the United
States for example um you know there's
two a two billion dollar
um lithium deposit and name that's being
held up from mining because of
environmental regulation for example so
when it's too hard to do that sort of
activity in the United States
China has no such qualms right so um
really the answer here is going to have
to be removing government red tape
and also technological innovation and
you know again I'm optimistic because I
think actually there's an increasing
bipartisan awareness that you know uh of
just of that reality
before we get to uh solutions to tackle
the the ESG problem or you know what
could practically be done to unwind some
of these these mistakes that you're both
arguing have been made
um I want to go through some of the
questions that people have left and if
you're a live viewer right now on
YouTube or Facebook now would be a good
time to throw in some more but uh this
is from Ben he says ESG isn't a threat
to capitalism and anyone who thinks is
the clown asks companies that don't want
to have an ESG plan we'll still be able
to operate and most people will stop
supporting them over time so he's
arguing kind of the opposite of what
you're saying that uh ESG uh people are
just not going to want to support uh
companies that are not conforming to ESG
because they're not going to be
perceived as socially responsible is
there any truth to that well I'll go
first and the first thing I'll say is
that you know there is there are
significant numbers of Americans who
actually believe in this stuff
if you look at things like particularly
those who sort of came of age in the
2010 there's a lot of who will say they
want their investment choices to align
with what they call their their personal
values right and that goes on the left
and the right so that's that's that's a
phenomer and the ESG people are picking
up on that that's a type of Market
signal that's going on so so and many of
those people may well invest despite the
fact in some of these funds despite the
fact that it's not actually in their
long-term interest I mean people will do
a lot of things that have nothing to do
with their economic self-interest
because they're ideologically convicted
of certain things so I think we need to
keep that in mind
but it's also very clear that
um certainly on significant sections of
both the progressive wing of the
democratic party but even the non let's
call it the more moderate wing of the
democratic party there's a lot of
pressure now to regulate this stuff into
place so that it gets harder to sort of
opt out of all this it's harder for
companies to opt out of these types of
uh of situations because if you try and
opt out you will lose quote unquote your
social license to operate and that's a
serious threat
there's a couple here that I'd like to
throw to Ross because I think they're
somewhat related uh this one is from
Fear the honey badger ESG is classic
Fascism and then the Republic of Texas
says eventually to have a high ESG score
they will have to have customers that
have high ESG scores bam backdoor social
credit scores I think what both of these
are kind of getting at is like where
does this lead
um you know I don't want to be the uh
too paranoid about this but you can kind
of see where people are coming from
where
in what say the composition of a
corporate board should be well the neck
the the path that that leads towards is
something like China's system where they
actually have government Representatives
on the board and suddenly you have a
all-out uh you know
um corporatist state where it's uh you
know the blending of public and private
is that a serious concern when we think
about ESG and stakeholder capitalism or
is that kind of just uh you know
overflown libertarian paranoia
all right it's absolutely serious
um and one thing we haven't talked about
and this is probably my fault but it the
banking side to this right because you
know I don't have shareholders right so
I don't have to worry about activist
shareholders the way a publicly held
company might but you know I do use
banking services right and um banking uh
companies
um and you know again to Sam's Point and
my point earlier they're not these CEOs
aren't just waking up one day and
deciding to do this out of the goodness
of their hearts you know they're
realizing that the whole of the federal
government you know as well as the
Federal Reserve right is is basically
saying you guys have to start doing ESG
so they're not crazy you know they're
going to do what The Regulators want
them to do but that being said what that
means is effectively
um they are allocating Capital they're
making loans now incorporating ESG
criteria into the decision right and you
know that means means that if you are a
small business owner and something you
do is perceived as ESG unfriendly it
might very well be more difficult for
you to get a loan or you might have to
pay a higher interest rate um you know
that's a very real concern and if you
look at
um you know again other countries such
as China this is very much happening
right so the Techno the technology
exists
for this to be done it's a question of
whether we're going to let it happen I
think that's very unlikely frankly in
the United States and you know and I do
want to say too that there have been
some proposals from the right to
essentially just ban ESG outright and I
do not support them
um and I will explain why
um because uh as Sam mentioned earlier
um you know this stuff goes back a long
time and you know it's not new per se
for someone making a loan or someone
evaluating an investment to consider an
environmental or social factor or
especially not a governance Factor right
they they in fact I would argue that
they probably should be considering
these things
so
that by itself if you start Banning that
um that becomes a massive imposition on
these Banks and it's really going to
discourage economic activity and access
to financial services in your state or
in your country where that happens so
the the issue is not that they're you
know considering these factors it's that
they're being pressured to do so in a
top-down way which is really leading to
uh prejudicial decisions it's also
reflective of I call it schwabian
stakeholder capitalism because what you
just described is this sort of subtle
blending and sometimes not so subtle
blending up public and private
that's corporatism baby that's what it
is and if you look at the things that
Schwab has written like the book that
you mentioned uh right at the beginning
Zach that he wrote on this subject
he literally talks about
1950s Germany as the model that he has
in mind for this and this is this is
very much now of course Germany has this
sort of flourishing liberalized economy
but it also has this very strong
Cooperative side to it and that is when
he when he made that reference I said
yeah this is really just corporatism uh
geared up for 21st century challenges
and then moved on to a global scale now
I'm not a conspiracy theorist I I don't
think that there are people out there
poliding to do nefarious things and the
way the conspiracy theorists typically
do but it is very clear that there are
there are significant portions of
political leadership around the world
who do see this as a way of they would
call it reimagining capitalism I would
call it emptying out capitalism leaving
a sort of Market facade leaving a sort
of private property facade but
underneath
everything is really about collusion
just to wrap up here I want to talk
about what are some ways to combat this
or you know keep it at Bay Russ
mentioned uh some of the efforts that
have come from the right this is the
text of a bill Marco Rubio Advanced
called the mind your own business act
which is kind of an an anti-esg Bill uh
which you said you opposed these kind of
efforts Russ because you I assume that
it's kind of trying to dictate in the
other direction that you're not allowed
to have uh you know environmental
related goals in your your company
charter and and that's uh kind of
equally
intrusive is that is that your reason
for uh finding you know what Rubio's
trying to do there misguided
yeah
also you know generally corporate law is
a matter for the states I don't like the
idea of federal government getting more
involved in it
um you know for a variety of reasons but
um you know also I think that Marco
Rubio example is interesting I wrote an
article for the National Review about
this which is that Marco Rubio despite
that bill has also positioned himself as
one of the foremost critics of
shareholder Primacy and in fact an
advocate of right-wing stakeholder
capitalism so he wants to mandate
shareholder Primacy but at the same time
he hates it I can't figure that out but
I think it's just indicative of you know
basic fact which is that the right of
Center you know which I count myself
among them
um it's late to the party here and we're
just sort of scrambling around trying to
figure out what's going to work now I'm
actually still nonetheless optimistic
because we have facts and economics on
our side in the law but um you know we
are late so not too late but late
um and then you know another Point here
though is I have concerns about specific
policy responses to ESG but I do think
that there are appropriate policy
responses to ESG you know just to begin
with
um I do not think that the SEC should be
imposing
um ESG on anybody nor the Federal
Reserve nor anyone else so you know
obviously to the extent that there's
legislation to prevent that from
happening I think that certainly makes
sense you know also a big piece of this
is State Pension allocation right that
is certainly an item for policy so you
know there have been proposals to just
clarify that if you manage a public
pension you should be putting the
beneficiaries of that pension first and
not some side social or political call
that you have which shouldn't even need
to be said but Utah and Florida are two
states that have have done that yes um
but but you know again we're late to the
party here because that solves one
problem yeah right which is
um you know how essentially your money's
being um allocated but then there's also
the question of voting and engagement at
corporations and and Ryan Zorn who's a
who's a researcher on this issue he
actually found that Florida and Texas
have been nonetheless voting in favor
of ESG proposals at corporations right
so even once you've solved one problem
only a new problem pops out so
absolutely there is a role of government
here I just think that we need to be
um careful and strategic about how we
approach it to avoid self-contradiction
and avoid things that are going to have
unintended consequences and I would
agree with everything just Russ just
said and I'm I'm I said a right guy as
well so and I think we're absolutely
late to the potty and the only thing I'd
add to what Russia said is that the
proposals of people like Rubio and
others to sort of use law to sort of
forbid companies from doing X or Y it
sort of reflects a more General problem
on the right right now which is wanting
to use the state to hit back against the
left and to my mind when you start
getting into that that mode of thinking
you sort of become a bit of a
progressive
I I and I I think like maybe the best
way to finish up here uh Sam is for you
to offer kind of an alternative Vision
uh or strategy to that since you've
written a whole book about the future of
the global economy
uh the conversation talking a lot about
the dangers
um what would a course correction look
like what is um a more optimistic future
for you know a 21st century economy
well certainly in the context of the
United States I think it's a it's a
future that takes entrepreneurship a lot
more seriously free competition a lot
more seriously and Embraces Dynamic
trade a lot more seriously but also even
beyond all that which in course involves
pulling back regulation all the things
that we tend to be in favor of
uh those of us who believe in markets
and believe in capitalism just have to
get a lot better at making strong and
normative cases for these things I
mentioned before the problem a lot of
business people have in explaining what
it is why they do why it's good it's
more than just profit it's it's good in
itself and all the good things that it
enables uh if those of us on the free
market side don't get better at that
because we're good at economics we're
greater policy but I think we've often
fallen short when it comes to the
normative side of things and the left
are very good at that the left are
exceptionally good at that whether we
like it or not and until we are get
better at doing that and that's one of
the things that I've tried to do in my
new book
um I think we're going to be on the back
foot
and what what about
um sorry just the uh this last question
came in I think might be an interesting
one to uh kind of contemplate on our way
out uh would someone like Elon Musk
coming out against ESG and declaring
that well as we saw earlier he did come
out against ESG but declaring that he
and his companies will not do business
with ESG companies be enough to stop the
central planning in its tracks and that
kind of hearkens back to earlier in the
conversation when we were talking about
all these ex-ex Executives being willing
to speak out against ESG but not a lot
of people that are currently in the
corporate world they kind of gotta walk
on eggshells
um could some high-profile people like
Elon Musk and other CEOs kind of changed
the tide here is that kind of a
potential path out of this
uh yes
um it's it's necessary but not
sufficient and I would you know um Elon
Elon statements about it have been great
but he's not the only one
um uh Jamie dimon uh some of you uh may
recall his response to Rashid at slab
you know when she asked uh why he's
still investing in oil and gas and he
said that to stop investing would be the
road to hell for America
so it certainly helps to sort of
um break the taboo
um for more Business Leaders to start
talking about it but you know I would
also say that
um I think it's important that it not
just be politically charged or
politically aligned Business Leaders
that are taking it because you know the
concerns we have with with stakeholder
capitalism and ESG aren't strictly
partisan they are things that a Democrat
just as well or a non-partisan
non-political CEO should understand and
every company depends upon America's
free enterprise system in order to
succeed over the long run so
um really this should not just it should
not just be an issue for right-wing
um aligned people like Elon Musk it's
great that he's doing that but it should
not just be Elon Musk speaking up
against this stuff and and it cannot
just be people like Elon Musk speaking
up against it if we're actually going to
be successful here
I think that's a great place to leave it
I want to thank both of you for joining
me on the stream today and thanks to
everyone who tuned in and who will watch
it later uh I'll be back next week uh
Nick Gillespie will be back as well uh
thanks again guys uh talk to you later
thanks Zack great thank you